ich wollte in meinen ersten 100 tagen im
amt 100 millionen impfungen in die arme
der menschen bekommen
heute abend kann ich sagen dass wir
dieses ziel nicht nur erreichen sondern
auch übertreffen werden wir erreichen
dieses ziel schon an meinem sechzigsten
tag im amt kein anderes land der welt
hat das geschafft
jetzt da wir alle arbeit geleistet haben
werden wir bis ende mai genug impfstoff
für alle erwachsenen in amerika haben
das ist monate früher als geplant
unser usa-korrespondent herbert
bauernebel ist für uns in new york und
steht vor einem impfzentrum herbert du
bist ja übrigens auch schon geimpft wir
haben gerade das versprechen gehört von
us präsident joe biden im mai sollen
alle erwachsenen geimpft werden
wie schaffen usa das ja man wird sehen
ob das einzuhalten ist es ist ein
ambitioniertes ziel aber joe biden wie
man ihn wie man gerade vorher gehört hat
hat ja bereits angeführt dass er seine
erste versprechung bereits übertroffen
hat 100 millionen impfungen in 100 tagen
das ganze wird jetzt nach 60 tagen
bereits erreicht und eben offensichtlich
gibt es auch gute nachrichten seitens
der herstellung der versorgung mit
impfstoff so dass eben bis ende mai
genug impfstoff vorhanden sein kann für
alle amerikaner und eben dieses ziel ab
ersten mal praktisch den im prozess zu
eröffnen für jeden bürger das ist ein
ambitioniertes ziel aber auch ein ziel
das für durchaus realistisch gehalten
wird derzeit und herbert was würdest du
sagen was läuft in den usa anders und
offenbar auch besser als bei uns hier in
deutschland
man muss sagen dass auch vorgänger
donald trump hierbei an dem frauen
wirklich vorarbeit geleistet habe
natürlich einerseits die entwicklung der
impfstoffe die stark unterstützt wurde
von der amerikanischen regierung in der
operation speed wie auch die tatsache
dass die amerikanische regierung einfach
genug impfdosen eingekauft habe im
letzten frühjahr und im letzten herbst
das ist auch sehr wichtig sein
amtsnachfolger joe biden muss hier
praktische gelobt werden für
seien es ist eine hemdsärmeligkeit beim
supercup mentalität wenn es um die
logistik wäre es um den ausbau der
infrastruktur geht hier in den usa und
hier darf man nicht vergessen
hier gibt es viel mehr importe wie in
anderen ländern man hat hier großem
ärger seit wie das jobcenter von dem ich
gerade stehe wo die nationalgarde mit
hilft aber auch kleinere importe wie
eben krankenhäuser arztpraxen
supermärkte apotheken und auch mobile
kliniken dadurch wird erreicht dass in
den usa jetzt 2,5 millionen impfdosen
pro tag initiiert werden in die arme der
amerikaner und insgesamt liegt amerika
jetzt mit einer bevölkerung prozentsatz
von 18 prozent von menschen die bereits
zumindest eine dosis erhalten haben im
internationalen spitzenfeld
jan joe biden hat ja auch schon kleinere
feiern wieder in aussicht gestellt zum
unabhängigkeitstag am vierten juli
wir nehmen die amerikaner diese
nachricht auf das ist natürlich ein
guter schachzug gewesen von joe biden
hier den vierten juli den vorschlag ins
spiel zu bringen natürlich der
amerikanische unabhängigkeit der
geburtstag eigentlich amerikas ist einer
der grössten feiertage amerikas und das
timing ist hier eigentlich fast perfekt
um eben diesen tag zu einem feiertag zu
machen auch in sachen corona virus
pandemie denn im frühsommer das sagen
auch viele experten dürfte hier
tatsächlich in den usa ein hauch von
normalität eingekehrt sein und es gibt
natürlich jetzt dann am vortag schon
einen großen moment wo die amerikaner
das auch feiern können teilweise hörte
sich diese rede von joe biden an wie aus
dem film hollywood film independence day
als er sagte wir werden an diesem tag
die unabhängigkeit vom virus erklären
das ganze ist natürlich ein wenig
politisches theater aber genau diese
hoffnung ist auch wichtig dass joe biden
einfacher mut den amerikanern mut macht
nicht nur breaking news nur bei bet
schaue ich hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren